you gotta really understand yeah this is
a freestyle it is a minute 45 second
long freestyle with no hook no bridge no
verse no nothing so again let me get
this straight because when you say
freestyle
for people like who aren't in the studio
a lot like there's freestyles and then
there's like yeah one
like punching off the top of your head i
don't know i'm not talking about just
like a freestyle where it's like i just
went in one take and just
there's different types of results with
that that's i'm talking about freestyle
in terms like just
the style of the record itself so like
there's no real structure to this
there's no real structure i've basically
proved that point with this there's no
rules to this music [ __ ] so like
with the structure of a record you know
supposed to be hook verse hook bridge
whatever it is you know i'm saying that
that certain standard of how you set up
your songs
again like i said with gallus there's no
hook no bridge no verse no nathan it's
just
a series of moments back to back
like a dj or something